China's war against coronavirus is being
waged around the country as it spreads
to every province and territory so far
the virus is winning with the number of
infections and deaths growing by the day
on the frontline in Hebei province where
the outbreak is thought to have started
the challenges made greater by a
shortage of medical supplies maceda dong
jung-ho and the trainees with the full
support from the Party Central Committee
the State Council and all the Chinese
people the shortage of medical supplies
has eased to some degree but protective
suits glasses and n95 masks are still in
tight balance and have to be scheduled
day long there's not enough medical
personnel either which the government is
trying to address by sending thousands
of extra doctors and nurses both
civilian and military to who babe much
of the province is shut down as
authorities try to contain the spread of
the virus but supermarkets remain open
and the government says it's trying to
maintain a steady supply of food at
regular prices we can ensure sufficient
supply for daily necessities such as
vegetables lamb beef pork and eggs in
supermarkets as foreign nationals are
evacuated from the provincial capital
Wuhan China's government has started
bringing stranded nationals home from
overseas the first charter flight
arrived in Wuhan from Thailand amid
reports of Hubei residents being
prevented from boarding commercial
flights back to China in Hong Kong
medical workers are threatening to
strike next week unless the government
does more to restrict the flow of
travelers from the mainland
while some border crossings have closed
flights from Chinese cities are still
operating the latest official statistics
show that on one day last week almost
10,000 mainland Chinese residents flew
into Hong Kong
it's that traffic that many people here
want stopped the government says
existing measures to control the
outbreak are working and stopping the
flow of people or goods isn't the answer
but critics say unless Hong Kong follows
the lead of some other governments and
closes its border with the mainland
completely this city could be about to
see a big increase in infections Wayne
hey al Jazeera Hong Kong let's speak to
Scott Heidler who is in Beijing so Scott
these us travel restrictions they're
pretty significant and what's the
reaction to this yeah it's very
significant now when you look at you
know what the w-h-o had been saying kind
of through the week and again kind of
reiterating that that they don't think
travel bans are the way to handle the
spread of this virus the Chinese
government responded to America's move
to ban non-citizens who didn't have ro
don't have relatives that are citizens
or who aren't close family members so
they they said this is not a move of
good faith so obviously that was kind of
a slight they felt by the American
government to China here in the midst of
this crisis the American administration
said it wasn't meant to do that but they
just feel as though they need to protect
themselves it's interesting it comes at
a time you know we heard in Wayne's
piece there that it's not just the
evacuation of foreign citizens leaving
Wuhan you know China has a lot of
citizens overseas that they need to try
to help and take care of and they're
doing that that flight in from Thailand
but also within China to their charter
flights because there are Chinese
citizens who are tourists in in the
affected area so they are also trying to
get them out of the impacted area
obviously testing them first and then
getting them to their homes so it's a
very big and difficult task to get
everybody where they can be and where
they should be in where they want to be
so this is kind of ongoing not just from
an international perspective but also
from an internal Chinese perspective so
Scott what is what is the feeling like I
mean this is this is the weekend
normally it would be a very very busy
weekend are people really just staying
home yeah this should be you know the
the Lunar New Year holiday would have
ended technically on Thursday that that
means that people some people would have
come back to work Friday yesterday then
we'd also see a lot more people arriving
this weekend Saturday Sunday and then
everyone to go back to work on this
delayed holiday extended holiday on
Monday but we're hearing from the
Railway Department here in China that
eighty percent decline in passenger
traffic on Friday and Saturday today so
obviously a lot of people are either
postponing their return
to Beijing or bigger cities from where
they've been during this holiday with
their families or they're just staying
put indefinitely and that's what we're
hearing you know right now the
government of the central government and
its offices its workers they're saying
essential workers will come back on
Monday
but then anyone who's non-essential
they're delaying at least another week
for them to come back you know you look
at Apple the American company they have
a lot of offices and a lot of operations
here in China they say that they have
delayed their they've closed their shops
and they've they're going to let delay
workers coming back into their offices
at least for a week that's something
we're seeing a lot with private
enterprises here now you know you look
at the economic impact of this it's it's
growing because you have these private
enterprises who are deciding to stay
shut you've got a lot of factories in
whom a province a lot of auto
manufacturing in Hubei Province those
are all standing idle now while they try
to figure out how to contain this virus
while they try to figure out how long
they need to keep this lockdown in place
so the economic cost is mounting as well
okay
Scott Heidler with the latest from
Beijing Scott thank you how does IRA's
Alexei O'Brien as in Bangkok where Thai
officials provided an update on the
virus there they have confirmed that the
number of confirmed cases remains
unchanged at 19 but the number of
suspected cases here in Thailand has
jumped to 344 from 280 on Friday they're
not saying that's because the virus is
spreading much faster here it's actually
because they've widened the net they're
now looking at people who have arrived
from cities outside of Wuhan via the
epicenter of that outbreak but also
Thais who may have come into contact
with Chinese tourists for example
because China is the biggest source of
foreign tourists for Thailand they have
been about two million people come
through just in December and January
since the outbreak began so if you have
a look at the map behind me though there
has been a map made up to show the
outbreak as it stands at the moment that
big red circle is will Harlan and
China's herbo province the as I said the
center of that outbreak and down a
little bit here you can see the red
flashing dot that is Bangkok and that's
because the Thailand has the second
number of highest of cases at 19 outside
of China and
also authorities here say Thailand
remain remains the most at-risk country
outside of China because of the number
of people traveling back and forth but
that number 19 is dwarfed by the number
if you moved with me here two of eleven
thousand eleven thousand three hundred
that's the number of global cases most
of them though are in China